what are the key steps in developing a
web series I know you said before it's
not really a film script so you can't
really divide it up and just say oh
great well these two pages are gonna be
the first episode you know you've got to
design it especially it sounds like for
that five minute time period I think the
most the most important thing is you
have to have a character that you that
you feel will hold the audience's
interest and he or she has to be
involved in something that is relatable
so using something that's of personal
interest to the creator is it's probably
one good way to start start with an area
of expertise that you're good at there's
a guy named Ed and I forgotten his last
name but he had a web series and his was
about a guy who was a chef and the guy
just he he he could create great food
with the women he just couldn't do it
and he what he did was he started off
with that premise you know what is that
what does a guy got to do you know and
the fact that he eventually became you
know became a chef you know shows his
the trial and error of him eventually
becoming a chef and eventually making
contacts and it's very funny because one
of his favorite things as he goes to the
same sushi shop a couple of times a week
and the real reason he goes is not just
because he likes the sushi because he
has a crush on this one gal who works
there and unfortunately he sees this
asian guy come in and giving giving you
know give me the gal hug and everything
and then and all this and saying I
missed you and all this so he thinks oh
my god she's got a husband or a
boyfriend so you know and she's
interested in him too you know and she
flirts with him and and always asking
him oh how are you doing and all this
it's really cute and it turns out by the
end of the first season at the I think
the last episode he finds he finds out
that that's her brother
and and then the the the love interest
starts as the love interest and
everything grows from that but it's
starting off with something that you and
maybe in an area that you know about
like in his case
it was in fact his I think his uh his
web series cuz it's called pairings
oh okay you know mm-hmm and so you
usually think of pairings is like okay
what wine goes with this kind of dinner
or whatever but it talks about you know
it's it's a play on words about you know
what it was like for this poor guy who's
a good cook but just can't see he can
cook everything and anything but he just
can't seem to get a gal yeah but he did
he take this from his own experience he
was a chef or he is a chef yeah okay and
in fact he uses that as a way to
advertise what he does is he will say if
you subscribe to our you know to our web
series and it doesn't cost anything to
subscribe and in his case it didn't he
says
I'll you know you'll get this week's
recipes oh yeah so something a little
different but just something that's you
know which kind of makes it interesting
for the viewer and the fans and as it
turns out this guy now is going to be I
think at last I heard somebody told me
that he was planning on doing a cookbook
and that there's also an olive oil
company I believe and a winery that
advertised now so he got sort of it so I
mean he didn't purposely go out to do
that so we were talking a little bit
about you know well I have to find a
sponsor first in this case the sponsor
sound right so so build it and then wait
you know sort of that then don't feel
filth of dreams yeah and there's a don't
but don't set out to have a beer only if
you don't have the story mm-hmm you know
you you know I
in his case he just was fascinated by by
web series and he always you
enjoyed writing and telling stories so
for him to do that and to you know his
day job was was being a chef right and
so it he combined the two of them and so
I think that's you know there are no
okay first you do this this then that
you know there's it's hard to it's the
same thing as any kind of writing you
got to sit down put your button the
chair and do it that's that's the first
step and he you know most of the
successful web series I've seen a lot of
them started off by taking a character
not unlike sometimes themselves and
trying to see okay what area of what is
the surrounding what's the environment
like another friend of mine that did a
web series did one she's lesbian and she
notices there weren't any lesbian
webseries and she wanted to talk about
the fact that a lot of people don't
understand that really you know no
matter what your sexuality is people
have stories and they have the same
fears and the insecurities that all of
us go through when we're in a
relationship and so she did did one and
it's it's in Australia and it's called
starting from now and it's becoming an
internet sensation they have fans all
over the world and they want a lot of
awards but she took the world that she
was in and she thought how can how can I
do something that's going to be
interesting and yet you know and and
have characters that I think people are
gonna care about and when you look at it
they those characters they worry about
their job just like we do they worry
about what their families are gonna
think just like we do they worry about
what the political situations are like
or what they worried about people
cheating on them it's it and you see all
of those things play out they are now
finishing up I think they may have
finished up by now their fifth season oh
so they've done incredibly well what's
the name of that one comes starting from
now starting from now okay and it's just
it's based in Austin
you but you can see it here I mean you
can just google it you'll it'll come up
you